do you guys think is weird that chad is
the whitest name ever and the blackest
place on the planet no one in Chad has a
friend named Chad being from Chad West
Africa is like being from Muhammad
Wisconsin can you imagine an African
dude named Chad oh I love lacrosse and
the Dave macho's bad all lives matter
you guys might notice I moved a little
slow getting out here because I'm
recovering from knee surgery toughest
thing about recovering from knee surgery
it takes me twice as long to get around
because now I have to give the black man
nod to black people and disabled people
[Laughter]
last week I saw a white girl in a
wheelchair I stopped dead in my tracks
and said Maude we're gonna have some fun
tonight my full name is Khalid Abdul
Rahman my parents converted to Islam
back in the 60s cuz just being black
wasn't difficult to know they had to get
bad Negro extra credit they were ap
Negroes some of you guys did well in
high school the rest of y'all didn't get
that joke I'm okay with that it's tough
being black at most up in 2017 I put a
clip of my stand-up on YouTube in the
comments someone wrote why don't you go
back to where you came from so now I'm
confused
is this person racist Islamophobic or
one of those people who really hates
Brooklyn
I feel though no I shouldn't complain my
little brothers got it bad my little
brother is black Muslim and gay yeah the
day after the election I called them up
and said hey bro you might want to drop
one of those
you can't be all three some of you guys
are really enjoying this the rest you
are distracted trying to figure out my
look I will save you the trouble
I look like Steve Urkel went to Urban
Outfitters
I had a crazy upbringing I went to a
radical black nationalist middle school
and I can tell from looking around most
of you guys did too you guys know the
best part of going to a radical black
nationalist Middle School
instead of singing the star-spangled
banner they told us to sing the black
national anthem lived every voice and
sing you guys know the words sing along
lift every voice and sing in the front
till earth in heaven ring ring with the
Harmony mom man
bertie the why man is evil and all this
has been thaw why man must pay in blood
for the sins of this P I'm starting to
you guys don't know the words to the
song fun fact to the show a couple weeks
ago
afterwards all black lady was up to be
and says young man I know those aren't
the real lyrics but they should be
you